des millions de tonnes de blé étaient
coincés dans les ports ukrainiens depuis
le début de la guerre contre elle a
réussi et on évoque déjà une possible
crise alimentaire mondiale
mais après des mois de négociations un
accord signé à istanbul relâche la
pression sur le marché mondial des
grains
dizaine grimalt
l'ukraine produits 12% du blé exporté
dans le monde tout ça dernière récolte
soit plus de 20 millions de tonnes et
entreposés en attente de la réouverture
des dangereuses haute maritimes de la
mer noire contrôlée par l'armée russe
l'accord très attendu sera d'une durée
de 4 mois à louis ii
et nationaux des partenaires
d'autres événements en contrepartie si
les russes ont obtenu la garantie que
leur propre récolte de blé ne feront pas
l'objet de sanctions internationales
pour les experts l'accord est une bonne
nouvelle même si la solution est
temporaire c'est important présentement
dit de sortir la graine l'ukraine parce
que l' école nouvelle récolte ça
commence à peler maintenant donc des
capacités dans vos achats en ligne en
ukraine malgré cette entente washington
reste sceptique quant à la bonne foi des
russes tout comme ottawa on a zéro
confiance en rendant la russie j'ai pas
confiance juteau en admire poutine selon
le fédéral la surveillance étroite des
activités russe en mer noire est une
nécessité
nous allons s'assurer que tous les
moyens qu'on a pour sortir c'est grey
100 mètres plus à risque l'ukraine soit
au coeur de toutes les discussions
pendant ce temps la guerre se poursuit
et plusieurs récoltes continue de brûler
dans le sud est de l'ukraine de nos
jours les fermes ils font ce qu'ils
peuvent dit cet homme mais les récoltes
sont fragiles ils doivent parfois
travailler ou risque de leur vie ce
normand grondin radio canada montréal